rogers network resuming after major
outage hits millions of canadians this
is a reuters story july 92 days ago
roger's telling communication said this
network was beginning to recover
late on friday after a 19 hour service
outage at one of canada's biggest
telecom operations shut banking
transport and government access for
millions drawn outrage from customers
and adding to criticism over its
industry dominance nearly every facet of
life has been disrupted with the outage
affecting internet access cell phones
landline phone communication
connections some callers could not reach
emergency services via 9-1-1 calls
canadians crowded over
crowded into cafes and public libraries
that still had internet access and
hovered outside hotels to catch a signal
pretty wild for this to happen 19
hours when i read it i almost thought it
was a movie and i'm like now i message
people is this really happening yep this
is exactly what's going on in canada
right now
so this is one network rogers is it
that's all they have tyler rogers
network is that their main network that
they have
i'm pretty sure that i've never even
heard of another one except so lady sent
me a message here's what she said
private message she said saw your tweet
canada i think you'll find people here
who are afraid to speak up publicly it's
very scary we're working on an exit
strategy to get assets and family out of
the country thank you for posing this
question hopefully people will start
talking also love your work especially
your content webinar preparing for
recession but i definitely love adam the
most so here you go that i added at the
end thank you very much appreciate that
okay here we go with about 10 million
wireless subscribers and 2.25 retailer
subscriber rogers is the top provider in
ontario canada's most populous province
and home to this biggest toronto uh city
toronto rogers bc
and tell us uh control 90 of the market
share okay so this is not just a small
company that this is happening to no and
i've i've heard people are pretty upset
with the monopolization of that they
have i mean the outsized market share
that they control is that ninety percent
they control ninety percent of the
market full-on monopoly what point does
it become a monopoly 40 that's exactly
there's different numbers uh that you
hear about forty six percent sixty-four
percent but there's different numbers
but ninety percent of your percentage
monopoly and you messaged this yesterday
and instagram and uh raul came back with
a pretty interesting point that this is
what remember dr peter pry talked about
if you had uh
a uh
not a solar flare but brought the
network down it would be something
equivalent to this shutting down the
banking systems television phone lines
everything would shut down
it's pretty interesting i'm gonna i'm
gonna show you something uh uh tyler i'm
gonna give this to you put this up on
the big screen so people can see it
uh this is a shout out to the prime
minister of uh
uh canada he's so he was walking in
canada and people were shouting at him
and it was not friendly because when i
posted this a bunch of people from
canada
sent me a bunch of tweets look at this
data here okay um
debt
from a pre-trudeau
all the prime ministers combined since
1867
630 billion dollars in debt
just under trudeau 662 billion dollars
in debt
that's a big number right there i mean
trudeau must be very competitive to put
a number like that okay
you know and by the way if you if you
keep doing that to a country that
doesn't have the biggest gdp in the
world 666 662 in america is what
nothing but 662 for a canada that's a
lot of money right there well now it's
nothing i remember during 2008 the
recession when we were going to bail out
whoever we were bailing out we were it
was still in the billions it was still
like 900 something billion
now we don't bat an eye
when we're cutting checks for trillion
we printed what five trillion dollars
since the pandemic so we're in the
trillions now they're still working with
billions they've got some catching up to
do
by the way you must have some strong i
mean we've we've sat down with jordan
peterson here canadian yeah this was
during the you know the truckers revolt
that they were doing
um in ontario we've had uh dr gadsat
here recently basically saying i've gone
into business with the canadian
government they take
60 of my earnings i run into canadians
all the time i had a couple saw a couple
of buddies uh that i ran into in miami
this weekend basically saying i got to
get the hell out of this god forsaken
country what the hell is going on in
canada is it just becomes so far extreme
socialism is it is it trudeau is just
an authoritarian disguised as a nice guy
what do you think is happening in canada
asking him are you how is he new i mean
it's exactly what happens when you give
somebody too much power
and their motives are not positive
motives the results are this
you know what's taking place in canada
and the reality of it is a lot of people
that were messaging me they were all
saying the same thing we're trying to
figure out a way to leave here with our
assets okay when we left iran
this is the story that most people don't
hear about maybe you have stories like
this as well a lot of people when they
left iran
the
the people that left pre
shah's revolution they left with their
money
but the people that left post shah's
revolution and khomeini came in they
couldn't leave with their money so the
money was left so if you'd like let's
just say you sold the property in iran
and you wanted to bring your money to
the states that wasn't easy to do so
imagine you're living in canada you got
a million bucks there you got half a
million you've been working 40 years and
you've got a half a million bucks you've
got a million dollars saved you're
trying to come to the states
you know you want to take that out i
don't know if that's the case but if
they're going in this direction of doing
things like this
it's a scary side so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here